Hey how's it going my name is Baba today
we're playing three cat crossing it's a
brand new RPG horror maker game that
looks amazing I don't know anything
about it I've just seen some pictures
the art style looks so cool it's been so
long I don't do you even remember last
time we played an RPG horror maker game
that sounded weird
I miss this so much one of the like my
favorite horror games have been these so
without further ado let's begin
yay I'm in a forest just what I wanted
don't get hit by a car please oh no it's
a crying lady hey are you okay what's
wrong are you lost
I'm scared I just went again it's not a
good voice for her it's pretty late do
you know where your house is
yes well then that settles it good talk
it's this way are we gonna follow you is
that what we're gonna I can take you
home if you want there you go don't you
want to go home this is mysterious I
like her outfit I want to wear it okay
Jesus Christ was wrong with this thing
cold are we gonna give the scarf or is
the main character a girl or a boy it's
a girl right better too tight ah it was
in your phone it wasn't your fault
here let me fix it for you better warm
great by the way what's your name cat a
cat by the road huh
nice to meet you Kat let's take you home
well this is [ __ ] eerie and [ __ ]
are those trees kind of look like a you
can eat them I need a tree
oh [ __ ] that was close I don't like to
where this is going
you know something bad is gonna happen
there you go straight cat crossing looks
really cool so far
we did that yeah you know one died this
is your house
yes very spine
are you sure Jesus Christ do you got a
triple doubt me every time
yes well then take care catch oh my god
again goodbye
was that cool um thank you hey wait my
scarf dad damn it I can't lose that
scarf why not it's a Burberry sort of
burberry scarf I like how he walks like
all right we're going in feeling we're
gonna regret this but hello door is open
uh yes whoo nice and common here maybe I
can have a nice cup of coffee in here
while I'm at it
what are these trails she missed a gun
this way
well I better father then oh my god what
is this
hello basement cat are you in here it's
a dog oh girl you got like beautiful
sound
what does [ __ ] look look look at the
Hang look what the cat ready the [ __ ] I
guess I guess we must look our best
we've never had a guest before a sight
for sore eyes isn't it it's a sore lie
isn't it what is going on
isn't it is it a [ __ ] who who are you
don't be showing us in hey the [ __ ] of
that pillow thing hear that hear that
weird that well she never met us did she
did she did she freshers in here she I
want their outfits too
have you seen a little girl around
little girl little girl aren't you a
little girl I guess I'd like to leave
please
she likes to leave to leave the nap the
pee with grief sir way out out yes damn
yes a favor
I declare our favor you can't just
declare a favor a favor all of the favor
and then shakily the damn the PE I love
this character uh all right what's the
what's a favor our favorites yes please
miss it's not a hard task this - oh God
what the [ __ ] you were set pile of mud
here that thing that that was a payload
can you tell me it's name hey then you
can leave oh that sounds like a good
favor leave us behind how unkind the
name what's the name of the pillar
oh god it's ugly that is not that ain't
no dog I gotta tell his name so I have
to return once I know its name
okay well let's get out then and maybe
we can find it somewhere oh it's still
locked
well I think there were some more space
over here do I move faster left and
right
Oh something here who are you Oh God
picture sure oh you saved that way this
is wonderful so far I miss these games
they have so much charm and always a
good story a planet model a dead bird
chemicals what is this
maybe this book will have answers let's
read it may 18 1912 to be honest I find
their back garden
okay well that was just gibberish okay
so the extract of rose it's the key word
what it does that mean we can take this
test tube's okay that's good
we can take all kinds of [ __ ]
chemicals okay so now we have taken the
test tube's
and collected the potions I think we're
gonna use it over this wine that's what
I Oh God all right cool that wasn't
creepy at all you guys are still here
with your little dog huh
well don't mind me I'm gonna Swan this
yeah okay it does it for me cool whoo we
did it yeah awesome
okay this is cool now we go to another
basement because who doesn't like a good
basement this is not creepy at all hey
man how you doing oh no it's all nuts
great an old film reel pick it up you
know any time I see an old film reel I'm
just like I'm gonna pick that up is that
Beethoven someone important all right
well it looks like Beethoven the
projector is running by itself play the
film yeah all right Oh God
babyface ha ha ha
search
what how did that happen
ah son what
okay bravo Bravo
what is snuck up on me it's offering an
egg no I refuse fine I'll make an
exception cuz you're so cute thanks for
the egg buddy thanks for the egg
my main man my main [ __ ] a player
guitar what is this painting memory of
dr. Johan Faust could Faust maybe be the
dog's name that's not a bad Oh God stop
doing those Jesus Christ on a bike oh
[ __ ] it was correct
unexpected correct correct connect house
fall play I suspect must be must be must
be must must we ask for another favor no
no you don't you don't ask for more
favors I just wanted the scarf Oh God
we mustn't hate her another favor we'll
write the wrong favorite for favors we
did you a favor bring us the favorite
food of the RAM now scram hahaha
I don't know what they eat I genuinely
don't know it's a Faust all right we
know that now our Ella sue is say yes a
picture will have a picture there we go
okay well this is this is going okay so
far I would say I mean has Oh God
well I think that means we need to write
it read it reread this as well
the clover concentrate sharpens the mind
allowing me to understand dead languages
oh that's not so creepy at all
there's a red inscription on the skull
at em here the first half of the
inscription is missing drink the green
potion why not feeling great yeah
feeling great okay so I drank the green
potion which made me understand what it
said on the skull that it says what does
the RAM see the RAM is the dog right oh
[ __ ] there's the RAM I'm so stupid
that's a ram what is the RAM see it
seems something here
there's nothing there Oh what oh that is
awesome okay we Prague oh god stop
and that's fine now big deer a lonely
peanut on a plate well ice never say no
to a lowly peanut be an old buck after
dawn you mean an Teldar don't you a
creaky stool okay this is really awesome
so far so let's give the peanut to the
Nutcracker man or the RAM oh god I
thought I'd go through up it smelled
weird and this skit yes yes I brought
his favorite food what do you want okay
we got to make him open it so we need
the Nutcracker after all that's fine
easy to fix
let's go say hey hey hey hello and give
him the nut let him chew on it chew on
this [ __ ] it's it's not a peanut it
looks nosy I can tell that thank you
mwah oh yeah okay really what please
come back later
why okay does that key me does he eat
key either he eats keys or we can
actually leave now yes
Oh for [ __ ] sake wood where does the key
go then the mouth is chained and locked
shut
unlock the mouth with the key yes two
conjoined hearts fell out of the roof
oh my god am I gonna feed that thing
[ __ ] hearts that's disgusting
yes I brought your favorite food yes yes
yes yes the RAM loves to devour human
hearts Oh God correct correct impossible
impossible
you couldn't have no you could adapt No
you couldn't have known oh now now where
we'll allow it but but but famous for
famous famous for famous that means you
still owe us one more goddamn favor god
[ __ ] damn it one more famous singers
the perfect song with the perfect voice
okay no problem
ass ugh oh god please do I have to all
right well this is the clue must be here
the clue must be in the music room what
instrument oh god well you moved thanks
for that let's go inside here now a
chicken oh god a chicken
good God our cat I can go forever he's
covering something can we maybe give it
the egg why are the lampposts indoors
beautiful
I learned a song okay
how would we do that let's try it see
what happens
skims really fun okay yes
that was perfect hahahahaha
but your voice it's repulsive yeah [ __ ]
repulsion repulsive well I tried all
right I don't know what to tell you this
is not a dog all right well I don't know
what to tell you then oh there's a dead
bird yes
let's use the blue okay we got an alive
bird
let's give it to the chicken this all
makes sense yes yes see oh god not oh
god what that [ __ ] indifference okay
that's fine
no big deal no big deal at all thank you
so much game for giving me that okay
it's [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ] this game
what if I play the piano
all right likes the piano oh so cute
well the bird will sing it of course it
all makes sense I mean it I mean I
thought I thought I sang it pretty well
but I guess he's this blue bird will
will kill this [ __ ] snip that I was
perfect perfect
what Oh a little birdie dead things
should say dead [ __ ] a date you killed
her
[ __ ] a day [ __ ] and dang couldn't they
what are they hey hey well you want you
won but you didn't have a black but
didn't you have a blast
yeah why leave so fast so soon after
that wonderful tune say why don't you
stay a while
a while haha think you're swell you're
so swell can't you tell okay you can
tell well well uh no no no you really
must go now that blows ha ha ha ha
can I go now please this is a really
awkward conversation well we promised
him me we did didn't we
who you will be missed I don't the door
to the outside and something you can
leave if you want
if you want we're going what's gonna
happen I don't seem too happy about it
I don't think we'll actually be able to
leave a to jump over shift to move well
okay or I can just do this oh [ __ ] my
stop I'm stuck now aren't I
okay Gus ah
hey it's you fix it yes he won't let you
go you know okay we're gonna in the
first episode there this is really
really cool and really really
interesting if you want more of this
prose I need your support
leave a like in the comment and I will
know otherwise I don't know you want
more and I don't know how to tell you
but this is so much fun to play
I'll see you brush it's always in the
next video stay awesomeness
you